the ivy is an evergreen plant
symbolizing eternity fidelity and strong
affectionate attachment one of his
oldest and most historic traditions is
the planting of the class IV a
collective binder represents the
graduating classes growth and
everlasting friendships every year the
graduating class selects a location on
all campus to be home to its classes IV
plant at the same location the class EO
is engraved into the bricks of all
campus since the class of 1852 first
planted a spring of ivy to commemorate
itself the Ivy ode has annually
described the symbolic connection
between the growth of the ivy vine and
the flourishing of the graduating class
the class Day program traditionally
includes a recitation of the ivy ode
accompanied by a class IV at the podium
by tradition our committee will select a
location of on campus for the ivy plant
an engraving which everyone will be able
to see and visit in the future today we
are excited to hear the IV oath
performed by Vincent borne of Pearson
I'm happy to report that Vincent has an
IV plant with him in Florida while this
is of course not our class IV it is a
reminder of the ties that connect us to
generations of alumni without further
ado we present Vincent's old compelling
us to overcome hardship and fight for
our dreams
in ode to fight we were taught to dream
dream big dream often dream for those
whose lives are long forgotten dream for
your teachers who planted the seed dream
for our ancestors whose only hope was to
be free
I still remember sitting in Miss penny
Howard's 9th grade chemistry class she
was the type of teacher that would stay
in extra two hours to review material
drive states away to support you at your
track meet and come pray with you if
your loved one was in the hospital too
every one of her thousands of students
she was more than a teacher she was a
mother who wanted to see all of her
children succeed before school I would
often find myself camped out in Miss
Howard's bright color-coordinated
classroom I would go to get help with
homework but more importantly to voice
my concerns about my future my family
and what would become of me at the time
as an adopted first-generation son of a
truck driver and library clerk I could
not genuinely imagine that an Ivy League
school
would ever accept me but for whatever
reason mrs. Howard with her
all-encompassing wisdom could see past
all of that she knew that I could
overcome what I thought to be
insurmountable challenges and remarkably
eight years later as a senior at Yale I
can still hear miss Howard in her thick
Southern drawl reassuringly telling me
honey as long as you work hard you can
do anything you put your mind to I'm
sure that we all had at least one mrs.
Howard in our lives motivating us
pushing us and making us boldly dream
for things out of sight
and now when these unprecedented times
for unknown future we will certainly
have to fight fight for your classmates
for the goodbyes we never got to say
fight for the memories we had in our
hearts they will forever stay fight for
the impoverished who work tirelessly
under the beating Sun fight for those
who need but a drink of water but
currently have none fight against
misogyny
yes we must combat fight not just for
representation but to close the gender
wealth gap fight for the climate which
is constantly changing fight for the
IceCaps we are so selfishly rearranging
fight for when you looked in the mirror
and said this is too much to take fight
for those lonely nights you stayed awake
and thought yeah yo made a mistake fight
for equality for our rights we can never
fold fight for yo winning championships
ho boy that never gets old
fight for your grandparents alone into
the quarantine softens when all of this
is over
we will visit them more often fight for
your cousin behind bars he tarries fight
for those who do not fit the gender
binary fight for the depressed who smile
and insist I'm fine don't let a friend
drown an anxiety oh because you don't
have the time now dreaming is nice and
certainly not war the dissing but let us
remember a dream is but a fairy tale if
all the hard work is missing reflect on
this moment this diploma took effort and
a whole lot of time because we all know
that Yale was very much a grunt Baskin
today we finally achieved it we told
ourselves we could and we apparently
believed it we're graduating now yeah
it's pretty sweet
but when injustice arrives don't you
dare take a seat we founded companies
formed on Broadway in way too many other
things to say but when the world is in
trouble
let it be yay Li's who saved the day so
now let's take these newly held degrees
and bring our knowledge to the fight let
each and every one of us go forth and
share that Luke's in paratus light thank
you and congratulations to the great
class of 2020